supongamos que trabajo en un restaurante
donde me pagan 10 dólares la hora pero
además de eso gano propinas por ahora
esta expresión de aquí representa lo que
gano yo en una hora dada ahora podemos
notar que la cantidad de propinas puede
cambiar drásticamente de una hora a otra
puede cambiar pues por ejemplo a la hora
de la comida hay mucha gente mis
propinas suben mientras que una o dos
horas después ya hay menos clientes y
entonces mis propinas bajan entonces la
propina aquí toda esta palabra la
consideramos una variable puede cambiar
de un momento a otro así por ejemplo en
un momento dado en el momento de la
comida que hay mucha gente podría estar
recibiendo digamos 30 dólares de propina
hay mucha gente ganó 30 dólares de
propina así es que en esa hora mis
ingresos totales son de 10 + 30 dólares
vamos a ponerlo aquí en esa hora mis
ingresos totales son de 10 más las
propinas
y 10 más 30 dólares así es que eso va a
ser igual déjame hacerlo con otro color
esto es igual a 40 dólares ahora
supongamos que a la siguiente hora los
clientes bajan ya pasó lo de la comida
quizás el restaurante de al lado tiene
una gran oferta y entonces mis propinas
descienden drásticamente a digamos 5
dólares en esa hora ahora regresando a
esta expresión mis ingresos durante esa
hora son 10 dólares mi salario por ahora
más los 5 dólares de propinas lo que me
da un total de ingresos durante es hora
de 15 dólares como puedes ver en esta
expresión el valor de mis ingresos
cambia de acuerdo al valor de la
variable propinas ahora tú no verás que
se usan las palabras completas en
álgebra para designar variables los
matemáticos nos da flojera usar palabras
completas entonces usamos sólo letras
quizás entonces en este contexto en este
ejemplo veremos que la ecuación se
representaría como 10 +
donde representa las propinas que recibo
en una hora y entonces qué pasa cuando p
es igual a 30 bueno cuando p es igual a
30 déjame escribirlo aquí abajo cuando p
es igual a 30 recibo aquí tengo p igual
a 30 si es que recibo 10 más 30-40
dólares durante esa hora que pasa cuando
p es igual a 5 cuando p es igual a 5
recibo 10 más p que ahora es 510 más 515
dólares durante esa hora ahora quiero
que quede claro no necesariamente tenía
que haber sido p no necesariamente tenía
que haber sido una letra aunque en
álgebra tradicionalmente usamos una
letra podríamos haber escrito como 10
más x donde x son las propinas por ahora
aunque no es tan natural como la letra p
de propiedad o también podríamos haberlo
escrito como 10 más digamos estrella
donde estrella representa las propinas
por ahora aunque esto no es tan
intuitivo pero espero que esto te haya
dado una idea general de lo que es una
variable simplemente es un símbolo
simplemente es un símbolo que representa
valores que cambian valores que varía
y es por eso que les llamamos variable